13.8 billion years ago the entire
universe emerged from one single point
in space
this theory is known as the big bang and
it's the most widely accepted story of
the creation of our universe
scientists came up with this Universal
origin story when they observed that
every single galaxy in space is moving
away from us even today
that means that at one point in time
everything could have been condensed
into an infinitely dense spot known as a
singularity
this Singularity was really hot too
other evidence of the Big Bang is
something known as Cosmic microwave
background it's radioactive remnants
from the early days of our universe
remnants that you can only see with the
help of a telescope
but what if we have this all wrong
what if the universe didn't start like
this
what else were we wrong about
this is what if and here's what would
happen if everything you knew about the
universe is wrong
I'm sure you're not looking forward to
the end of the universe but glancing at
its future demise could flip your
understanding of the universe and its
Origins
before we unravel the mysteries of the
universe let's talk about something
serious March is mental health awareness
month and it's time to fight the old
stigma that you have to struggle in
silence especially when forty percent of
American adults report living with
symptoms of anxiety and depression you
know on average it takes about 11 years
for someone to seek treatment after
symptoms occur mostly because people
can't afford help now while these
numbers are scary it does mean one thing
you're not alone
right now this Administration is working
to make mental health care more
accessible like through schools
expanding Telehealth support and
providing more funding for CDC programs
let's break the silence and if you're in
need check out the resources available
to you in your area the universe is a
lot better with you in it
okay so you know that our universe is
continually expanding outward so you
might assume that it would likely
continue expanding forever well this
could be true and this is why the most
widely accepted Theory involves the
universe doing just that it's called the
big freeze
and what's really cool about this is a
mysterious and invisible force that
makes the universe expand
it's called Dark Energy and it makes up
69 of the universe's Mass
another 26 of it is made of dark matter
and only five percent of the universe is
plain old ordinary matter
if all this material originated from one
point and just kept expanding eventually
all this heat and energy would be very
very spread out
at a certain point everything would be
so far away from each other that the
entire universe would reach a
ridiculously frigid temperature
absolute zero absolute zero is the
lowest temperature possible
it translates into zero Kelvin or if you
prefer a more familiar temperature scale
minus 273 degrees Celsius
by the time the universe reaches this
super low temperature you wouldn't be
able to see any distant galaxies from
your Vantage Point in the Milky Way
don't worry though that would be at
least a couple of trillion years from
now
that's just one Theory it's also
possible that the death of the universe
will be the exact opposite of this
instead of expanding forever the
universe could shrink back together
time for the Big Crunch
all of the matter in the universe taken
as a whole has an unimaginable amount of
gravity it might be enough gravitational
force to battle the mysterious dark
energy and win
if this big crunch were to happen the
universe would start to contract in on
itself
Galaxy clusters far away would merge
eventually stars and planets in our own
Galactic neighborhood would Clump
together too and this increasing density
would heat up the whole universe
all that Cosmic microwave background
radiation from The Big Bang would get so
heated that it would be hotter than
Stars
we're talking 5 000 degrees Celsius hot
the universe would become a scorching
chaotic mess
as temperatures continued to rise and
more mass got crashed into a teeny tiny
region atoms would start to break apart
the universe would be turning into the
densest black hole possible
while that would certainly be the end of
the universe as we know it it might just
be the beginning of a new one
and that would be proof that our
universe is much much older than we
thought
the universe may have formed itself over
and over again in this violent cycle of
contraction and expansion you wouldn't
have the slightest chance of surviving
to witness this epic event firsthand no
one would so for now all of this is just
an end of times Theory and it has a big
name the big bounce
it suggests that the Universe expands
and contracts all the time just like a
lung that breathes in and out only in
slow motion and not just once or twice
according to this Theory there may have
been billions trillions or even an
infinite number of universes both before
and after hours
each time the universe reforms it could
create completely different laws of
physics
this would create all kinds of strange
possibilities
there could be universes with no life no
stars and not even an atom in sight
now this is all pretty wild and it gets
Wilder from here some scientists debate
that everything we know about our
universe is
wrong
what we know about the cosmos is based
on what we can see and study in our
Galactic neighborhood then we assume
that it works like that everywhere else
in the universe
the idea is old and it's called the
cosmological principle
but we may have been wrong all along
it could be that the way our Milky Way
galaxy moves through the universe is
distorting our data I mean we've never
had any hard evidence to confirm our
theories so there's no way of seeing the
bigger picture from where we stand
this is where you could be starting to
doubt whether any of this is real to
begin with
surely our universe the one we can see
must exist right
well not so fast
you have quantum mechanics to thank for
what I'm going to tell you next
scientists who study quantum mechanics
theorize about the nature of the
universe on an atomic level
and according to some scholars in this
field the universe must be one of two
things real or local
bear with me here I know this can be
mind-numbing
if the universe is real that would mean
that it has specific properties like
color and mass that exist even when
you're not looking at them for example
take a red ball
if it's real the ball is red even when
there's no one around to look at it
on the other hand the universe could be
local
this means that the Universe can only
exist because we are there to observe it
through our telescopes so if you think
about the red ball again without anyone
around to observe it it could have any
color or no color at all
only when you look at it and see that
it's red does it actually become red
that's quantum physics 101
but there's a catch the universe could
be either real or local it can't be both
and remember that the universe is
ridiculously big it could be infinite
our telescopes just aren't powerful
enough to observe all of it
so that means we can't know for sure if
the universe is even real
[Music]
you didn't see that coming did you
well that should be enough of a head
scratcher to keep you pondering about
how everything really came to be where
it all could eventually go and what's
the meaning of it all anyway
but hey why stop there wouldn't it be
cool if the universe were actually like
a giant brain
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]